[MUSIC PLAYING]
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Hello,
I'm Magnus Hyttsten
for "The Developer Show."
We're here at the
TensorFlow Dev Summit
with Andy Selle, who just did
a presentation on TensorFlow
Lite.
So Andy, what is
TensorFlow Lite?
ANDREW SELLE: So TensorFlow
Lite is our product
for doing fast and small mobile
inference on small devices that
are resource-constrained,
like mobile phones.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: So
it's not for training,
it's more for
inference on a model.
ANDREW SELLE: Right
now, it's for inference.
But in the future, we're
going to explore training.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: OK, excellent.
So what kind of
applications can we
imagine out there being
built on TensorFlow Lite?
ANDREW SELLE: So there are
several Google Apps out there
today that employ
machine intelligence that
are switching over to TF Lite,
or already have switched over.
So some examples are Google
Photos, the Assistant,
and Smart Reply.
And you can see more about that
if you look at our talk log.
But one of the great
things is that once you
make it easy for any developer,
not just like a machine
learning expert, to
run fast inference,
app developers are
going to transition
to being able to put
this into every app
and use it for applications
we can't imagine.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: How
does this actually
work on a mobile device
that's small and has
battery constraints and
all of these things?
ANDREW SELLE: Yeah,
so TensorFlow Lite, it
was architected
from the ground up
to work on really small devices.
So that basically
means that we want
to keep the binary size small.
So when somebody
downloads an app,
they don't have to wait
a long time to do that.
And also we want to
make sure it's fast,
so when they do something they
don't have to wait a long time,
or that app developers can
use it where they otherwise
wouldn't be able to because
it wouldn't be a good user
experience.
So once we're fast enough
and once we're small enough,
every developer can
put it into every app.
And it will allow
lots of things.
And we frankly
can't imagine what
apps app developers will do.
One of the great things
is that they're creative
and they can use it
in all sorts of ways.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Super cool.
And we mostly talked
about mobile apps here,
but in fact, TensorFlow
Lite goes way beyond that.
We had an important
announcement today.
ANDREW SELLE: Yeah,
so for the first time,
we showed Raspberry Pi.
And that's a single--
it's a cheap
single-board computer
that uses a cell phone chip.
But it basically
has allowed schools
and allows individuals
to afford many computers
to do robotic applications.
It can interface with lots
of different hardware.
You can plug motors into it.
So this is going to be a really
good gateway for hobbyists
to get into machine
learning and running it
for all kinds of
interesting applications
that are multimodal with device
outputs and multiple sensors,
again, because they
can put sensors
that the cell phone
manufacturer--
you get your cell phone.
It has one device or
you can't change it.
But this, you can plug
in whatever you want.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: And it's kind
of a bridge to the Internet
of Things as well, right?
ANDREW SELLE: Yeah, exactly.
In fact, so it's
Raspberry Pi, but it
could be any Linux-based
system-on-chip computer
will work fine with a minor
tweak to, say, the Makefiles.
But TensorFlow Lite
is so easy to port
that it's not really
that hard to do that.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Super cool.
So the question
on everyone's mind
is how can I actually get
started with TensorFlow Lite
if I'm a developer?
ANDREW SELLE: So
this is really easy
because it's all on GitHub.
And the documentation is
all on tensorflow.org.
So we released this last fall,
so it's been there for a while.
So you can play with it now.
And we're excited to
hear all your feedback.
We're excited to see
what you use it for.
We have a mailing
list as well now,
which is tflite@tensorflow.org,
in addition
to the GitHub and the website.
MAGNUS HYTTSTEN: Super cool.
I'm Magnus Hyttsten.
This is Andy Selle for
"The Developer Show."
We're at the
TensorFlow Dev Summit
talking about TensorFlow Lite.
[MUSIC PLAYING]